[Musique]
cette balle ne va jamais raté un
parterre a raté les amis aujourd'hui on
va parler on va apprendre des choses on
a parlé d'un truc que j'aime énormément
qui s'appelle l'effet de groupe se
déroule ya quelques mois on avait sous
forme de jeu puis parler de la théorie
des jeux voilà c'est un jeu qui a été
développé par nikki kaïser en gros
nikkei c'est un mec qui aime bien à
travers ces jeux apprend des choses aux
gens en effet la sociologie
essentiellement aujourd'hui on va en
savoir plus sur l'effet de groupe qui
n'a jamais été un gros connard au milieu
d'un groupe parce qu'il est influencé ou
est ce que je veux dire
voilà vers ce qui n'a jamais été
influencé positivement par son groupe
beuve bienvenue sur son odieux qui
s'appelle la sagesse et ou folie des
foules et ça va être très intéressant
moi en tout cas c'est un sujet que
j'aime bien encore plus que la théorie
des jeux mais on y va ça a été traduit
par clem kéru la merci club pierre
rollin on adore tous ces faux sir isaac
newton était plutôt sûr d'être un malin
après tout avec l'invention du calcul
différentiel et la théorie de la gravité
il aurait dû être assez intelligent pour
des investissements financiers et non
offert cours il a perdu 4 millions six
cent mille dollars dans la folie
spéculative nationale appelée la bulle
de la mer du sud de 1720 comme il l'a
dit ensuite je peux calculer le
mouvement des corps célestes mais pas la
folie du peuple et oui tu peux prévoir
des maths sauf que le comportement des
gens c'est très complexe et très
difficile à prévoir
bien sûr ce n'est pas la seule fois où
les marchés institutions ou des
démocraties ce sont des traqués c'est la
folie des foules
et pourtant au moment où on perd foi en
l'humanité on trouve des gens qui
s'organisent pour se porter secours lors
des ouragans des communautés qui trouve
des solutions des gens qui combattent
pour un monde meilleur a contrario ça
s'appelle la sagesse des foules ça
montre quand même groupe peut se
comporter très très mal entre eux ou
alors ils peuvent
al'inverse avoir des super comportement
laisse tirer vers le haut et tout ça ça
dépend de ce qui les entoure alors
pourquoi certaines filles sont folles et
d'autres sont sages aucune théorie ne
peut tout expliquer mais je pense qu'un
nouveau champ d'étude la science des
réseaux peut nous guider son idée
centrale pour comprendre les foules il
ne faut pas regarder les individus mais
leur connexion pour sortir à cette vidéo
sera moins con si vous l'acquittez avant
vous serez plus con que celui qui l'a
pas quittée après j'ai pas ça pour vous
regarder jusqu'au bout je suis pas trop
d influencer de manière d'une autre base
à la suite d sinon un réseau chacun
représente une amitié entre deux
personnes lui il est copain avec lui qui
est copain avec lui
ce sont tous des amis et même eux
peuvent même être comparés date du coup
il ya vraiment tout le monde qui est
copain avec tout le monde nous regarde
et je relis tout le monde à tout le
monde c'est fou dans la vraie vie c'est
jamais comme ça vous avez forcément
croisé d'époque de potes voir des potes
de potes de patte de potes et on peut
des fois coupé un lien entre des
individus
j'ai fait un bruit de c'est pas sorcier
c'était naturel les connexions sociales
servat bien plus qu'à faire de jolies
images les gens se tournent vers leurs
connexions sociales pour comprendre leur
monde par exemple les gens regardent
leur père pour savoir quel pourcentage
de leurs amis sans se conter ce sont dix
ont de gros buveurs dessinée effacer des
connexions et regardez ce qui arrive
ok donc on a un schéma avec 4 personnes
2 2 ce sont des buveurs on voit ici que
lui il regarde juste lui que lui c'est
un buveur donc lui bat 100% de ses amis
sont des buveurs et si on le relit je
suppose à quelqu'un qui ne boit pas hop
le taux change seulement 50% des amis
sont des buveurs parce qu'il a plus que
lui et s'ils regardent hop le deuxième
afssa va être 33% ça c'est assez simple
à comprendre mais où veux-tu en venir
nikica is cependant les réseaux peuvent
tromper les gens comme la terre peut
sembler plate car j'ai fait un avc alors
tout comme la terre peut sembler plate
car on est dessus des gens peuvent se
faire une image fausse de la société car
ils en font partie en gros dans la vraie
vie c'est pas du tout aussi simple que
ça mais dans la théorie l'idée est bonne
dans ce qu'ils entendent présenter par
exemple une étude de 1991 a montré que
presque tous les étudiants d'université
ont rapporté que leur amie buvait plus
que commence la subtile et bien vous
allez inventé la réponse vous même en
dessinant un réseau il est temps de
tromper tout le monde c'est le moment du
puzzle fait croire à tout le monde que
la majorité de leurs amis sont de gros
buveurs même s'il ya deux fois moins de
gros buveurs c'est vrai qu'on voit qu'il
ya beaucoup plus ici de nombreux
éleveurs que de buveurs ils sont que 3
les buveurs sur un groupe de neuf
personnes mais si tous les non buveurs
regarde les buveurs bas qu'est ce qui se
passe
eh ben il va croire que la plupart de
ses amis sont des buveurs alors que pas
du tout donc là où ces gens pensent
qu'ils sont uniquement entouré de
buveurs alors qu'on voit que pas du tout
c'est terrible ce que vous indiquerez
s'appelle l'illusion de la majorité qui
explique également pourquoi les gens
pensent que leurs idées politiques fait
consensus
ou pourquoi l'extrémiste semble plus
courant qu'il ne l'est en gros c'est une
question de point de vue si on regarde
beaucoup plus les gens qui sont
extrémistes que les autres et ben on va
avoir l'impression que la majorité est
extrême et ce alors que pas du tout
seulement avec les réseaux sociaux et
tout comme les extrémistes eagle
énormément bas on les voit beaucoup
alors je ne sont pas extrémistes eagle
moins donc on les voit moins mais les
gens ne savent pas simplement
passivement les idées comportement des
autres îles les copies nous allons donc
maintenant regarder ce qu'on appelle les
contagions j'adore dessous nous avons
une personne rouge avec un chapeau avec
une information une fausse info une fête
news comme on dit et tous les jours
cette personne répond la rumeur comme un
vie
à ses amis qu'il à répondre à leur tour
à leurs amis et ainsi de suite comme la
gaffe que j'ai fait dans ma vidéo sur la
terre plate où j'ai dit que sur la lune
c'était l'ombre de la terre alors que
pas du tout c'est juste sa propre ombre
à la lune j'espère voulait pas répéter à
vos amis sinon je suis responsable d'une
fac news malgré le non négatif les
contagions peuvent être bonnes ou
mauvaises ou notes ou ambiguës il ya une
grande preuve statistique que fumer la
santé la joie les motifs de vote et les
niveaux de coopération sont tous
contagieux et même des preuves que les
suicides et les fusillades en sont
également donc on imite bel et bien ce
qui est autour de nous c'est comme ce
comme les chiens aboient natsu je vois
il apprendra prenant autour de lui
dessiner un réseau est lancée la
simulation afin que tout le monde soit
infectée par la contagion bas on voit il
suffit juste de relier d'un trait les
différents groupes de personnes et
ensuite le travail va se faire tout seul
quoi à balancer des défèque news la
bande de [ __ ] pas bon vous rendez
compte parmi un groupe de 20 personnes
il suffit juste qu'il y en ait une qui
ait reçu l'information pour la réponse à
tout le groupe et ensuite je vais avoir
une bonne partie du groupe qui va lui
même le répandre à d'autres groupes qui
vont même ça va très vite une fake news
c'est terrible cependant cette
simulation fosses à la plupart des idées
ne se répande pas comme des virus pour
beaucoup de croyances et de comportement
il faut être exposés à la contagion plus
d'une fois pour être infecté à il faut
qu'on nous dise l'information plusieurs
fois avant qu'on la vallée conte à
transmettre nous mêmes c'est intéressant
les chercheurs en réseau ont trouvé une
meilleure nouvelle manière de décrire
comment les idées comportement se
répandent
ils l'appellent les contagions complexe
maintenant 6 millions ce qui arrive
quand les gens commencent à boire quand
plus de 50% de leurs amis boivent avant
de démarrer essayer de deviner ce qui
devrait arriver
ok donc la différence avec le premier je
sais que un nom buveurs s'il a plus de
50% de ses amis qui sont buveurs il
devient lui-même buveurs d'après moi ils
vont donc tous finir buveurs
ah non lui la deux amis autant pour moi
je me suis planté sur le dernier lui
comme il avait trois amis clac clac clac
et qu'un hack un des trois qui étaient
buveurs qui bloque donc qui stoppe la
contagion c'est un héraut constamment la
présidente contagion des fausses rumeurs
cette contagion n'atteint pas tout le
monde est prêt la personnes ont été
infectées car bien qu'elle n'ait été
face qu'à un gros buveur celui ci
représente 50% de leurs amis oui ils
sont solitaires pâte en avoir deux amis
c'est déjà mieux que zéro hockey non
j'ai plus jeunes en moi j'ai plus que
deux amis quand même par contre la
personne à la fin de la chaîne n'a pas
été infectés car bien qu'elle était
exposée à un ami gros buveurs ça
représente moins de 50% de ses amis qui
sont des buveurs
cependant les contagions ne sont pas
nécessairement mauvaise ici nous avons
un volontaire pour je sais pas sauver
des gens lors d'un ouragan offrir des
cours à des élèves en difficulté du
quartier où quelque chose de cool de
genre cette fois ci cependant disons que
le seuil est seulement de 25 % les gens
veulent se porter volontaire mais
seulement 6 25 % ou plus de leurs amis
le font également alors aux yeux de tous
regardés lui je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
se regardent entre eux
oui les contagions complexe ne sont pas
nécessairement sage mais être sage et
une contagion complexe j'apprends cette
notion de contagion complexe dont
j'avais pas idée c'est intéressant cette
fois ci avec une contagion complexe ce
sera un peu plus dur et c'est d'infecter
tout le monde de sagesse complexe en
gros je peux pas juste faire ça et relié
ça marchera pas on va quand même le
faire pour voir mais en gros ça va
bloquer ici voilà ça va se transmettre
le premier groupe puis ensuite lui il a
trop de connections avec des gens qui
n'ont pas de sagesse pour que ça marche
alors comment on fait pour que ça marche
je pense que ça doit être lui qui
doivent transmettre uniquement aux trois
groupes différents et là normalement ça
devrait pas marché ok à mon avis il faut
que les groupes se passe le truc entre
il faut que le mec qui te transmet le
truc le transmettre à chaque groupe et
non pas uniquement au premier groupe et
je raison
oui c'est à dire que le mec qui est sage
transmet sa un groupe le groupe le
transmet à un autre mais ça marche pas
si lui qu'elle a au début le transmet
pas aussi bon vous dit peut-être suffit
d'ajouter des connexions pour répondre
une contagion complexes ou cinq bonnes
mauvaises sajoo folle mais en est-il
ainsi et bien revisitons un autre puzzle
précédent au nikica et sud où
travaillent les neurones mon ami si vous
appuyez sur démarrer la contagion
complexe va toucher tout le monde pas de
surprise cette fois ci faisant le
contraire de tout ce que nous avons fait
avant dessiner un réseau qui empêche la
contagion d'atteindre tout le monde
bah il faut juste que tout le monde
parle à tout le monde je pense est-ce
que j'ai raison attention up ces sables
bien qu'un nombre important de
connexions va toujours aidé à répandre
des idées simples cela peut gêner le
développement d'idées complexe c'est
trop intéressant je suis désolé clément
thème bien répondre à un avantage non
yes
les gens la nasa sont intelligents
pourtant 86 malgré les avertissements
des ingénieurs ils ont lancé challenger
qui a explosé tué sept personnes la
raison il faisait trop froid ce jour là
en fait les managers ont ignoré les
avertissements des ingénieurs pourquoi à
cause de l'effet de groupe qu'un groupe
est trop unis cela tend à être le cas au
sommet des institutions il résiste aux
idées complexes qui met en péril leurs
croyances ou leur ego les petits dessins
qui vont bien que quand monde se connaît
c'est beaucoup trop unis et ça résiste
beaucoup trop critique vos avis
extérieur donc à gauche il n'y a pas
assez de connexion et une idée ne peut
pas se propager dans le groupe ici on a
le problème inverse il ya trop de
connections donc on obtient une pensée
de groupe qui est très très forte
et au milieu ça nous trouver un juste
milieu pour pouvoir répondre une idée
complexe en gros la solution c'est que
dans un groupe il faut qu'il y en ait
qui ne se parlent pas je pense un ouais
c'est ça donc en gros on obtient ici des
groupes dans un groupe
contrairement à la hausse et un seul
groupe beaucoup trop unis et à là où il
ya carrément pas de groupes c'est
intéressant
peu importe comment se formuler les gens
à travers les époques les cultures
arrive souvent à la même conclusion une
société saine nécessite un équilibre de
liens à l'intérieur de groupes et de
ponts entre des groupes c'est à dire pas
ça parce que les idées elles peuvent pas
se répandre
ni cela car l'effet de groupe s'ils
manifesteraient donc quand quelqu'un
arrive pour donner une idée bas ça
passera pas mais ceux ci des groupes
emboîtés les uns dans les autres
sedaka des individus qui font partie de
deux groupes différents et il est vrai
ce mec là ça pour être toi tu fais
partie d'un groupe ici avec tes trois
autres amis mais tu fais aussi partie de
ce groupe là où il ya d'autres amis
qu'on était la question du tout début
pourquoi certaines poules deviennent
sage et ou folle mais oui en résumé la
folie des foules n'est pas
nécessairement dû à des individus mais à
comment on est piégé dans la toile
qu'hollande d'un réseau mais on ne doit
pas négliger sa responsabilité
personnelle car nous sommes aussi acteur
de cette toile ce que je vous disais
quand vous dites ça c'est que ça a
vraiment un impact
de faire du bien autour de soi ou de
faire du mal autour de soi ça a un
impact beaucoup plus grand qu'on imagine
donc pour améliorer vos contagion soyez
sceptiques des idées qui vous flatte
prenez le temps de comprendre les idées
complexes et pour améliorer vos
connexions créer des liens avec des gens
aux idées proches mais aussi au delà des
fossés culturels et politiques les
grands triomphes et tragédies de
l'histoire sont cause et non par des
gens fondamentalement bon ou mauvais
mais par des gens qui sont
fondamentalement des gens
neil gaiman et terry pratchett et par
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
c'est hyper intéressant effectivement
pourquoi pourquoi il ya des groupes
comme ça oubliez ça se tire vers le bas
et pourquoi ya des groupes où ça se tire
vers le haut on a vraiment un impact
autour de nous on se rend pas compte
même sur des trucs qui nous paraissent
loin de nous sur lesquels on se dit mais
non ça sert à rien c'est un jeu facile
que je fasse ça mais si mec parce que si
tu lui fais les gens autour de toi
peut-être qu'ils vont le faire aussi
peut-être que j'ai entendu qu'on le
faire aussi était que les gens autour de
vous le faire aux tous répercute c'est
un peu l'effet boule de neige en tout
cas j'ai trouvé ça hyper intéressant en
passer par le site de nicaise il ya
d'autres jeux dessus et c'est vraiment
hyper d un jour ça génial j'espère que
ça vous aurez un peu plus la prochaine
fois on sera là pour taper des barres
vous en faites pas la voilà j'avais
envie juste de jouer à jeu quoi et tout
jouer seul chez moi je trouve ça cool de
vous en faire profiter n'hésitez pas à
mes lèvres de ciel vous a plu si vous
voulez d'autres vidéos comme ça dans les
mois à venir pourquoi pas j'en ferai
peut-être une par mois une vidéo on
apprend des trucs ça fait du bien un peu
je trouve je fais plein de bisous je
vous dis à très vite pour des trucs un
peu plus drôle pour péter en vidéo voilà
tous les ans fin horrible quand je peux
faire de truc c'est différent d'une
vidéo halo à très bientôt
[Musique]